in today's money watch we have financial
advice for recent college graduates and
their families especially if they had to
borrow for school right now americans
owe more than 1.7 trillion dollars in
federal loan debt the average federal
student loan debt balance is more than
thirty seven thousand dollars cbs news
business analyst joe schlesinger is here
to help new grads tackle that debt in
their overall finances good morning how
are you doing i'm great all right so
these uh these federal student loan
payments are suspended through august
31st
how can recent graduates prepare for
those upcoming payments i got to start
by please warning folks that you know
you saw that number that the average is
about 37 or 40 000 of outstanding
student loan i'm hearing from a lot of
students who are like well it's probably
just going to all get erased right so
don't count on worry about fingers
crossed exactly i think that there is a
possibility that 10 000 does get erased
and it may be weighted based on how much
money you earn but don't count on
everything being gone and so when you
think about what is my average student
loan debt what is the payment that i
need to make you need to go into the
system figure out what you own oh and
make a list be sure to understand what
is the interest rate that it will be
charged for you as of september first
and sure if you're lucky enough great
some of it is gone but beyond that
you're prepared as if you're paying off
the whole absolutely and you know before
the before we had coveted the most
common payment that people had was say
two or three hundred dollars a month you
know you hear these terrible stories
it's thousands of dollars there are
cases like that but most common we're
trying to get people to pay off that
debt within 10 years of graduation and i
think a lot of these kids really can do
that so how do you start joes to even
have a responsible financial life if
you're you're starting a new career
hopefully you've got a job and you have
student debt how do you even begin to
to do to make the best use of your money
i think this is a great moment for
people to just sort of take a deep
breath and say hey i have a job because
we know that these students are actually
graduating into a very hot labor market
so many of them will have jobs and so
now you know what's coming in from that
job how much money you're going to make
the problem is we don't like
concentrating on what's going out so
what we really want to focus on is what
are you spending money on and that may
mean that if you're not living with your
folks anymore maybe you're paying rent
for the first time in your life maybe
you have to pay for your food maybe you
have to actually figure out who's buying
that first round of drinks for you not
you buying for them and you say keep
track of all that got to keep track of
it you know that about two-thirds of
america does that joe one-third of
america
thank
i mean listen there are people like me
who love the spreadsheet there are tons
of apps out there actually millennials
are quite good at keeping track they've
been very good to do that so you want to
keep track of that money what are you
trying to figure out how much money can
you free up every single month to be
able to put money down on your debt
again highest interest debt comes first
because we know the kids are graduating
with student loan debt but there may be
credit card debt there may be an auto
loan you've got to price that out and
you say let me attack highest interest
debt first that's most important if you
are lucky enough not to have any debt
guess what you can start saving and
that's a beautiful thing
all right yeah miracle upon miracle you
got all your debt covered
how much savings is the goal what should
you shoot for you know when people are
coming out of school once you get that
debt cleared up i think that there's two
forms of saving
gail this is dedicated to emergency
reserve fund which i know everyone gets
on me for saying six to twelve months of
your living expenses and it could be
three months yeah but i like six to 12
because life is uncertain so you really
want to try to save as much as you can
in that emergency reserve fund but then
there's long-term saving and that may be
a retirement account so we're looking
for 10 or 15 percent it between the two
if you are looking at i've got debt i
have to save it in my emergency reserve
fund and i want to save for retirement
think of it this way your debt and your
emergency reserve fund are your primary
uh goals but that retirement account if
you've got a match from your employer
don't give away that money try to put
six percent there and you're whittling
it away the beautiful thing about
graduating right now is you've got time
on your side let's form the good habits
early and parents and grandparents help
foster that environment i'm glad you
brought that up you know in 2003 i was a
rookie in the nfl and i was being told i
need to focus on retirement i was just
trying to make the team
but they were right though
how important is it for young people
these recent grads to start thinking
about retirement right now i bet if i
did a poll of everybody on this set the
first thing they would say is the thing
i should have done is put as much money
as possible in my retirement plan as
early as possible yeah so let me be
clear about one thing we have high
inflation right now right what is on
sale relative to where we were six
months ago stocks and bonds right now
you can buy stocks at a 20 discount of
where they were six months ago guess
what if you're starting out in your
retirement plan right now you've got
time on your side you've had a market
that's in a bear market it is time to
get busy
get in the habit a little bit more every
time after whatever jill's retirement
plan you're gonna have five dollars
extra for the week yeah that's right
have fun don't go crazy